[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
niedrige Sirin Ihnen allen einen schönen
guten Abend jede Menge Sport und
Entscheidungen später mit Katja streso
und eine Eröffnungsfeier schönen guten
Abend dann schauen wir auf die Themen an
diesem Samstag
Ringen um europäische Asylpolitik auf
dem kleinen Parteitag streiten die
Grünen leidenschaftlich und drängen nun
auf Nachbesserungen
tausende unbesetzte Stellen die
Bundeswehr sucht Nachwuchs und lädt auch
deshalb in ihre Kasernen ein
und eine riesen Party nach der
titelsensation leidenschaftliche Ulmer
holen sich ihren ersten Basketball
Meistertitel
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mit Spannung wurde heute der kleine
grünen Parteitag im hessischen Bad
Vilbel erwartet spannend deswegen weil
sich viel Frust aufgestaut hat nach
schmerzhaften Kompromissen schlechten
Umfragewerten und zuletzt offenem Streit
wegen auch grüner regierungszustimmung
zum EU Asyl Kompromiss sehen viele in
der Partei inzwischen nur grüne ideale
schwinden wie laut sich der Frust
entladen hat dazu jetzt Andreas
in die hessische Provinz nach Bad Vilbel
hat es die Grünen verschlagen der Ort
gedacht als Rückenwind für die
Hessenwahl im Herbst doch seit Tagen
hängt der grüne Haussegen schief nach
dem Gerangel über das heizungsgesetz
spaltet jetzt die Verschärfung des
eu-asylrechts die Grünen wie lange nicht
die Parteiführung auf
Vermittlungsmission meine Bitte lautet
lass uns heute streiten und dann gehen
wir zusammen raus untergehakt und
kämpfen für das Richtige und das hat
geht nur wenn wir eine zentrale Frage
und nur diese eine in den Mittelpunkt
stellen wie wir den Menschen an den
Außengrenzen der Europäischen Union
helfen können beim urgrünen Thema Asyl
und Menschenrechte geht in Riss quer
durch die Partei von der Spitze bis zur
Basis es schmerzt mich dass es keine
verpflichtenden
verteilungsmechanismen gibt er schmerzt
mich dass diese Entscheidung auch einen
asylrechtsverschärfung für Deutschland
in der Konsequenz bedeutet es ist nicht
tragbar das Kinder und Jugendliche an
Außengrenzen inhaftiert werden
das ist nicht die Humanität die unsere
Asylpolitik braucht vor allem die
grenzverfahren bei denen auch Familien
mit Kindern in streng gesicherten Lagern
interniert werden dürfen sorgen für
Unmut die grüne Außenministerin hatte
dem zugestimmt rechtfertigt das ohne
deutsches Jahr hier keine Einigung über
eine gerechte Verteilung von
Flüchtlingen
wenn wir uns als Bündnis 90 die Grünen
nicht dieser Zumutung stellen dann
werden andere Entscheidungen fällen dann
hätten die Feinde Europas und
Menschenrechte Feinde der Menschenrechte
gewonnen am Ende beschließt der
Länderrat sich jetzt noch einmal auf
europäischer Ebene dafür einzusetzen die
grenzverfahren zu entschärfen der
parteiinterne Streit bei mir EU asylis
damit lediglich vertagt beigelegt ist
der sicher nicht
in Bad Vilbel ist Patricia Wiedemeier
für uns beim Asylkompromiss setzt die
Parteiführung auf Nachverhandlungen was
passiert wenn dabei nichts herauskommt
worauf ja vieles hindeutet
ja gute Frage genau das ist nämlich
nicht geklärt in dem Abschlusspapier das
heute einstimmig verabschiedet wurde ist
genau diese Frage noch offen geblieben
da steht nur man wolle nach Abschluss
des triloges das heißt der Abstimmung
zwischen EU-Parlament EU-Kommission und
EU-Rat dann das Ergebnis bewerten was
auch immer das heißt welche Konsequenzen
das hat völlig offen ich habe den
rechten Flügel gefragt also die real los
da hieß es nur naja wir haben schon
zugestimmt also werden wir auch dann
weiter zustimmen die Vertreter des
linken Flügels dagegen sehen das ganz
anders da hieß es dann nein wenn es
keine Verbesserungen gegeben hat dann
dürfen wir nicht zustimmen dann darf die
Regierung nicht zustimmen und müssen
sich enthalten die Koalitionspartner FDP
und SPD würden das natürlich ganz anders
sehen wenn es überhaupt in dieser
Legislatur noch zu einem Ergebnis kommt
also schwierige Frage alles offen was
die Partei der Grünen heute hier in Bad
Vilbel geschafft hat man hat diesen
Optimist einstimmig beschlossen es ist
erstmal Ruhe eingekehrt man hat eine
relativ sachliche Diskussion geführt
anders als im Vorfeld erwartet aber das
Thema Asyl ist nicht von der
Tagesordnung verschwunden vielen Dank
Patricia nach Bad Vilbel ja auch die CDU
hat sich zum kleinen Parteitag getroffen
und ringt um ein verändertes Profil nach
dem schlechten Abschneiden bei der
letzten Bundestagswahl will sie sich
anders aufstellen und ein neues
Grundsatzprogramm zulegen auf
verschiedenen Foren wurde über die
Zukunft der Partei gesprochen
Diskussionspunkte eine große
Steuerreform oder ein soziales
Pflichtjahr Beschlüsse gab es nicht das
Grundsatzprogramm soll nächstes Jahr im
Mai verabschiedet werden und mehr über
die Konservativen die einen neuen Kurs
suchen und die ratlos CDU wie unser
Hauptstadt kommentiert können Sie lesen
bei ZDF heute bzw in unserer heute App
wir schauen jetzt in die Ukraine bei
einem russischen Raketenangriffe im
Osten auf ein Dorf in der Region wurden
zwei Menschen getötet laut ukrainischem
Verteidigungsministerium sind im Süden
Richtung saporicia kleine Gelände
Gewinne zu verzeichnen die Kämpfe seien
extrem heftig über die Situation dort
berichtet jetzt Lena sünderbruch
immer mehr Krankenwagen auf den Straßen
und überfüllte Krankenhäuser saporissia
im Süden der Ukraine liegt etwa 60 km
von der Front entfernt jeden Tag werden
neue Kriegsverletzte hergebracht kolodie
mir erholt sich gerade von einer
Gehirnerschütterung nach einem
russischen Drohnenangriff an der
gefechtslinie sie haben mehr Männer mehr
Munition und das Leben ihrer Soldaten
ist ihnen völlig gleichgültig sie
schonen ihre Mittel nicht wenn ihre
Leute sterben schicken Sie einfach neu
wir haben nicht genug Artillerie die
Front ist sehr lang überall wo wir
anzugreifen versuchen warten sie mit
ihrer Artillerie auf uns und mit Minen
die die meisten unserer Verluste
verursachen
der regional Gouverneur bestätigt im
Schweizer Fernsehen die Schlagkraft der
russischen Streitkräfte ist trotzdem
zuversichtlich
nach und nachrücken unsere Männer vor
sie nehmen strategische Positionen ein
natürlich wird es nicht nur zwei Tage
dauern die Region saporicia zu befreien
wovon wir nur träumen können aber wir
machen weiter
doch auch Russland macht weiter
Verteidigungsminister Scheu GU besucht
heute eine militärfabrik in Sibirien
lässt sich Panzer und Waffen zeigen und
verlangt noch mehr davon nach
Einschätzung britischer Geheimdienste
hat Russland 20 zusätzliche
Kampfhubschrauber in der Region
saporicia stationiert und ist so im
Süden der Ukraine zeitweise überlegen
zum Bundeswehreinsatz im
westafrikanischen Mali den will die
Bundesregierung wie geplant erst Mitte
nächsten Jahres beenden so eine
Sprecherin gestern hatte der malische
Außenminister vor der UNO den sofortigen
Abzug aller UN-Soldaten gefordert
aktuell sind noch etwa 1.100 Bundeswehr
Mitglieder in Mali die Militär runter
sieht in ihnen aber mehr Hindernis als
Hilfe und setzt stattdessen auf
russische Söldner um den Islamismus im
Land zu bekämpfen
bleiben wir bei der Bundeswehr der
Truppe fehlt Ausrüstung aber noch
gravierender sind die Nachwuchssorgen
seit Jahren stagniert der
Personalbestand bei rund
183.000 Soldatinnen und Soldaten bis
2031 soll die Zahl auf 203.000 wachsen
es wird aber noch viel mehr Personal
gebraucht denn zuletzt waren mehr als
18.500 Stellen oberhalb der
mannschaftsgrade nicht besetzt wie man
neue Köpfe gewinnen will davon hat sich
Oliver deuka beim Tag der Bundeswehr ein
Bild gemacht
etliche tausend Besucher sind zum
Heeresflugplatz Bückeburg in
Niedersachsen gekommen schweres Gerät
Vorführungen die Bundeswehr präsentiert
sich eine gute Möglichkeit um Nachwuchs
zu rekrutieren funktioniert das
eigentlich schon ich überlege aber wir
können nicht sicher wenn du zivile im
Büro
glaube ich nicht geeignet als Soldat
nicht unbedingt weil ich einfach nicht
unbedingt
diese Gefahr mir selber oder mich selber
dieser Gefahr aussetzen würde
risikojob häufige Versetzungen
dazugehälter die kaum mit denen der
freien Wirtschaft konkurrieren können
eigentlich schlechte Voraussetzungen
beim vorhandenen Fachkräftemangel die
Bundeswehr ist
sehr viel noch mal on top auch
finanziell Anreize bieten können alleine
das Finanzielle ist es aber häufig
tatsächlich nicht sondern es muss das
Gesamtpaket stimmen das wird er gerne
hören Verteidigungsminister Boris
Pistorius auf Stippvisite in Bückeburg
mehr Ausrüstung und Personal beides muss
er besorgen die Herausforderung besteht
darin in kleiner werdenden Jahrgängen
von jungen Menschen die Attraktivität so
darzustellen dass alle verstehen diese
Bundeswehr ist ein großartiger
Arbeitgeber und gleichzeitig ist das
Ganze verbunden mit einem hohen Maß an
Kameradschaft Zuverlässigkeit und
Freundschaft auch untereinander
Verlässlichkeit
rund 1000 Ausbildungsberufe und 50
Studiengänge hat die Bundeswehr im
Portfolio breite Begeisterung für die
Truppe hat das bisher nicht geweckt so
bleibt es schwierig ausreichend
qualifiziertes Personal zu finden
heute vor genau 70 Jahren begehrten
Männer und Frauen so laut wie nie zuvor
gegen das Regime in der DDR auf eines
der wichtigsten und stolzesten
Ereignisse in der freiheitsgeschichte
unseres Landes nannte Kanzler Scholz den
Volksaufstand des 17 Juni 1953 gemeinsam
mit dem Bundespräsidenten und anderen
Staatsspitzen erinnerte er in Berlin an
die Ereignisse von damals bei denen
viele ihr Leben ließen mindestens 50
Menschen starben im Zusammenhang mit der
brutalen Niederschlagung durch die
sowjetische Besatzungsmacht und den DDR
Behörden tausende Bürger landeten im
Gefängnis wie ein Flächenbrand weiteten
sich an diesem 17 Juni 1953 die
Demonstrationen aus rund eine Million
Menschen gingen schließlich auf die
Straßen Annette Pöschl hat Zeitzeugen
aus Magdeburg getroffen
50.000 Menschen ziehen am 17 Juni 1953
durch die Straßen Magdeburgs sie folgen
den streiken den Industriearbeitern
protestieren gegen die SED Regierung
Klaus kutschmann damals 12 Jahre alt
wurde wie alle Schüler nach Hause
geschickt und damit er ungewollt mitten
in die Proteste
es war ein riesige Menschenmasse damit
Plakaten teilweise mit sprühspenden
obendrauf freie Wahlen war das Thema
Wiedervereinigung war das Thema auf
einer Aufbruchstimmung da man hatte das
Gefühl die Menschen wollten was
verändern
ein Ziel politische Gefangene zu
befreien sie stürmen das
Polizeipräsidium werfen Schreibmaschinen
und Akten aus den Fenstern wenige Meter
weiter dringen sie ins Bezirksgericht
ein Hans-jürgen Anton beobachtet den
symbolischen Sturz der Regierung vom
Balkon
dann riefen Leute
Namen von
ddr-staatsführungsleuten hoch und dann
haben die oben die Bilder rausgesucht
und müssen sie mit der Richter Kleidung
runter was unten dann in das Feuer
geworfen wurde doch die Gefangenen
Befreiung scheitert allein am
justizkomplex werden sechs Menschen
getötet ab den Mittagsstunden Rollen
sowjetische Panzer die Besatzungsmacht
schlägt den Aufstand nieder
wir reden heute immer sehr viel von
Zivilcourage die notwendig ist und
Zivilcourage meint ja dort wo Unrecht
ist soll man sozusagen einschreiten
sondern Engagement zeigen das haben
diese Menschen damals getan und insofern
sind sie heute für uns immer noch ein
Vorbild
Zeitzeuge Klaus kutschmann wünscht sich
ein anderes gedenken in Gesprächen
jenseits der Feierlichkeiten nur einmal
im Jahr
bei einem nächtlichen Angriff auf eine
Schule im Westen Uganda sind mindestens
41 Menschen getötet worden die meisten
Opfer sind Kinder die Polizei macht
Rebellen einer islamistischen Miliz
verantwortlich die mit Macheten
bewaffneten Kämpfer hatten die
Schlafsäle angezündet und ein
Lebensmittel Lager geplündert außerdem
wurden mehrere Kinder verletzte und
einige offenbar entführt
einmal im Jahr füllen sich die Straßen
Londons mit tausenden royalen Fans dann
wenn der Monarch zu seinem Geburtstag
geehrt wird zum ersten Mal nahm König
Charles der dritte die traditionelle
Parade ab 6 Wochen nach seiner Krönung
mehr als 1000 Soldaten 200 Pferde und
hunderte Musiker zogen bei besten Wetter
durch Westminster Andreas Stamm
sichtlich zufrieden etwas erschöpft nach
zwei Stunden Parade lässt sich Charles
der dritte Feiern von tausenden aus
aller Welt vor dem Buckingham Palast es
sind seine ersten offiziellen
Geburtstagsfeierlichkeiten bei
Königswetter und so können die
britischen Luftstreitkräfte den längsten
Überflug der paradengeschichte
vollführen
ich habe die Queen geliebt und die würde
es lieben dass alle ihren Schals
unterstützen er ist gut
seine Geschichte und Wurzeln zu kennen
ist wichtig solche Feierlichkeiten sind
die Basis unserer Gesellschaft das
gemeinsame was uns ausmacht Kontinuität
erstmals seit fast 40 Jahren ein Monarch
im Sattel auf dem Weg die Parade
abzunehmen bei Sonnenschein mit
bärenfällen Mütze und voller
militärmontur kein leichtes Unterfangen
für den 74-Jährigen etwas luftiger hatte
es da die erste Reihe der Familie bei
den Proben waren aufgrund der Hitze noch
mehrere Leibgardisten kollabiert
als es drauf ankommt läuft es wie am
Schnürchen
vom Glanz und Gloria
und gott schütze den König heißt es dann
erstmals seit 70 Jahren wieder bei
schubing
Pannen frei und anders als bei der
Krönung vor sechs Wochen keine lauten
antimonarchieproteste vielleicht ist es
das schönste Geschenk für Charles bei
seiner Premiere Parade
ja wenig zu feiern gab es gestern bei
Fußball Länderspiel zwischen Polen und
Deutschland Katja wieder kein Sieg für
den DFB schlimmer noch das Team von
Bundestrainer Hansi Flick unterlag Polen
in Warschau 0 zu 1 ideenlos zeitweise
taumeln so der Tenor nach dem Spiel
Außenverteidiger Robin Gosen sagte die
Lage ist tot Ernst am frühen Abend sind
sie zurückgekehrt erneut eine Reise ohne
Fortschritte eine stagnierende
Mannschaft der beim 01 der Wille nicht
abzusprechen ist der jedoch Stabilität
und Sieger Mentalität fehlen voller ist
weiterhin überzeugt von Flick der
angesichts der Ergebniskrise immer mehr
in Erklärungsnot Gerät klar gab's doch
schon schönere Zeichen immer in meinem
Trainer in meiner Trainerkarriere
trotzdem ist es eine Sache die ja wie
wir gehen die an wir sind selbstbewusst
doch auch was unseren Weg betrifft aber
wir haben Spieler die gehen den Weg mit
und um das geht wir vertrauen da den
Bundestrainer ähm dass er weiß was er
macht weil er weiß was er macht
die Zweifel wachsen die jüngsten
Auftritte machen wenig Hoffnung dass
sich zeitnah Fortschritte einstellen
in einer Stunde steigt in Berlin die
große Eröffnungsfeier der Special
Olympics World Games die Spiele der
Menschen mit geistiger Beeinträchtigung
50.000 Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer
werden im Olympiastadion sein und einer
unter ihnen ist mein Kollege Florian
tierisch Florian was können wir heute
und in den nächsten 8 Tagen erwarten
ja wir freuen uns hier in Berlin auf
nichts Geringeres als auf das größte
Multisport Event Seite in Olympischen
Spielen
1972 mit 7000 Athleten und Athleten aus
190 Ländern und mit Vorbereitung die
deshalb schon tagelang auf Hochtouren
laufen unter anderem mit dem Botschafter
dieser Welt Spiele und Superstar Dirk
Nowitzki und auch mit den Vorbereitungen
auf die Eröffnungsfeier heute Abend bei
der wird dann nämlich vor den Augen von
Bundeskanzler Scholz der Bundespräsident
Frank-Walter Steinmeier diese
weltspieler eröffnen unter dem Motto
gemeinsam und schlagbar ein Motto das
hier in Berlin bis zum kommenden Sonntag
Strahlen wird mindestens hoffentlich
sogar noch länger
danke schön nach Berlin Florian und viel
Spaß heute Abend ja eine kleine
Sensation hat es in der Basketball
Bundesliga gegeben denn das Team aus Ulm
ist erstmals in der Vereinsgeschichte
Deutscher Meister die Ulmer gewann in
den Playoffs gestern Abend das vierte
Finalspiel gegen die Telekom Basketball
mit 74 zu 70 und entschieden damit die
Best of Five-Serie mit 3:1 für sich nach
dem Apfel gab es entsprechend kein
Halten mehr
[Applaus]
ist in Feierlaune und darf weiter vom
ersten Titel auf der ATP-Tour Träumen er
steht im Finale des Turniers in
Stuttgart im Halbfinale besiegte Strom
im Bild vorn dem Polen Hubert hookatsch
mit 3:663 und 6:3 im Finale wartet
morgen der an drei Gesetze der
US-Amerikaner Francis Tierfoto
[Applaus]
und das könnte aus deutscher Sicht eine
erfolgreicher Sonntag werden denn auch
die Handballer vom SC Magdeburg stehen
im Finale der Champions League es war
ein absoluter Krimi im Halbfinale gegen
FC Barcelona die Entscheidung viel erst
im 7 Meter werfen scmkeeper Mike Jensen
parierte den letzten Wurf der Spanier
entstand 40 zu 39 und morgen spielt das
Team von Bennet Wiegert dann entweder
gegen kelze aus Polen oder Paris
Saint-Germain
und könnte nach 21 Jahren wieder
Champions League Sieger werden vielen
Dank Katja beim Wetter gibt es ja weiß
ich nicht müssen sie entscheiden nicht
so viel zu feiern vielleicht doch es
wird ungemütlicher mehr gleich mit den
terli Grünen Chefin Ricarda lange im
heute journal Interview ab 23:15 Uhr mit
Dunja Hayali das war's von uns machen
sie sich noch einen entspannten
Samstagabend
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter aus dem Südwesten
erreichte uns warme und aber auch teils
feuchte Luft das erkennt man schon an
den Wolken und es kommt auch Regen dazu
in den nächsten Tagen gibt's dazu
Gewitter die liegen teilweise Anfang der
Woche sogar im unwetterbereich schauen
uns die kommende Nacht an und da gibt es
etwas Regen im Nordosten Richtung Ostsee
z.B das wird allmählich weniger
ansonsten ist es trocken die
Temperaturen sinken an den Alpen bis auf
9 Grad und 17 Grad am Niederrhein ja und
zu morgen dann einige Schauer im
Nordosten ansonsten meistens trocken
aber zum Nachmittag und späten
Abendstunden kommt von Westen her dich
Wirkung auf und da ist dann auch etwas
Regen dabei die Temperaturen erreichen
höchste Werte 23 Grad an der Ostsee und
maximal 33° hier Richtung Rhein-Main und
Oberrhein ja die nächsten Tage bringen
Schauer und Gewitter teils im
unwetterbereich mit stark Regen Hagel
und Sturmböen Montag bis 24 als 31 Grad
und am Dienstag sogar 32 Grad ein
schöner Abend